I'm an open book I don't I'm very
trusting that and that's why I've been
[ __ ] over so much all right I Todd
where you from I'm from I'm from San
Diego and you currently let me tell you
I currently live from San Diego I grew
up in Salinas California Monterey County
that's where I was raised and I can he
ended up in San Diego because my wife
got pregnant with triplets we lost two
and we have our oldest son is 27 he's
blind and has cerebral palsy and that's
how I ended up in San Diego because he's
in the hospital for so long but I have
another son it's in Long Beach that's
why I was down in this area he's going
to college to be a doctor so and that's
kind of how I ended up over here this
area ended up in Long Beach and I was
mugged there by a female and do you want
me to elaborate more on that okay well I
met this girl through these guys and I
had some stuff I was trying to sell and
she seemed pretty connected and and I
was very tired she doesn't get a room
for a couple hours I said sure I need
some sleep it wasn't even trying to do
anything with her and she offered me a
drink I took the drink within ten
minutes I was I was not feeling well and
I was out and everything else was in
like a dream and I woke up in the
hospital very irritated and very didn't
know what was going on and I could
barely talk and walk and they finally I
don't know why they kicked me out I
guess I was being a problem I'm not
quite sure I was like a dream and I
realized I wasn't in San Diego was in
Long Beach and it hit me that I was I
was robbed my truck was gone my tools
everything was gone and I did get my
truck back but everything everything was
stripped so they drugged you she drugged
me yeah la GHB or something something
she poured in the beer and her name was
uh oh she went by nice
[Laughter]
and so I stuck in my son's in Long Beach
for a couple of days because I didn't
have my truck and I called my brother up
who those in eleyne asked him to come
down we could drive around and I found
him and coughs can't anything do
anything about it anyways so then I came
down here and I met Savannah and she
approached me about you know having sex
and stuff and I said okay she took me up
to a room and she was actually very
hospitable and you know and just she was
cool she didn't burn me she didn't do
anything everything went well then I met
Tiki and that didn't go so well
she just she just worked me and worked
me and worked me my fault cuz I allowed
it and her boyfriend who goes by Frost
he ended up burning me for a $500 on
people card so I was done with them then
I met a girl named Alicia and she
approached me for sex innocent act and
she [ __ ] up I was so tired cuz I was
up she got me some crack weed I was up
for a while and I fell asleep and she
[ __ ] just walked me again I got
robbed and and the thing is all these
people I've gotten them you know most of
my bottom tint candy bought a tent you
know because it they needed it I got him
stuff and and I just been I just been
worked that was another one candy it
just it's just been one after another
one of them set me up and had a guy in
there and beat me and again attempted to
take everything but that point I was
didn't have anything left and but my my
addiction is what kind of brought me
here
means looking for adult what is your
drug it was cocaine as what I started
with and then I ended up in the 90s
started smoking crack crack crack is a
much more version of cocaine yes it's
more addictive you just want more and
more you just you just you just never
get enough of it and so that is my drug
of choice now and I've been through
number of programs and in and out and
claim for many years and I'm I'm very
successful when I'm not using it's just
I'm some somewhat functional when I use
to but it just takes me into the wrong
places and this and that like I said I
just been stuck here for the last three
weeks trying to get back up and just I
just had just been taken advantage of by
by everybody and then I met him grew and
he he told me about you but so if that
happens today I'm I'm I'm back to San
Diego today so your life in San Diego
you have a job yeah I do I do I don't
need to tell me to medium well I'm doing
a big job right now I'm doing a Rhema
complete room about this size I'm doing
a massage parlor putting plumbing
electrical all that and so you do
construction I do construction I was the
owner of a absolute construction for ten
years and you still working I'm still
working yes yes I do I've been stuck for
three weeks in Attica but you're a
little out of control right now I'm out
of control yeah I'm on I'm on a good one
you're under but I finally reached out
so what I do is when I go on a good one
I I lose all communication with
everybody I don't talk call anybody
and no I haven't talked to anybody in
three weeks finally I picked up the
phone to the guy he's waiting for
permits were at the stage he needs two
permits and he he's been calling me and
reaching out and I just I've been so
down and just beat up that I just
haven't talked in you but I did pick up
the phone yes you know he just says just
get back just come back just come back
he wants me to finish the job you know
so I told him I would let me see if I
can get some money together and get back
so
and are you still married yes yes and
what did you do you do this kind of
stuff in San Diego as well yeah I do
absolutely I do I was doing quite a bit
over there
and I know I saw I like I said the
reason I came over there was cuz I my
son lives in Long Beach and I kind of
worked my way over here yeah but but in
San Diego yes I'm also using there but
I'm working yeah I mean right but
certainly your wife must know something
oh yes she for years for years but the
thing is it's just like the people I
work for they know who I am when I'm not
using I'm very productive they just
can't believe Who I am when I because
I'm a very productive person I've always
had great jobs I used to be a plant
manager for fresh express running 200
people I'm a very productive person but
then I get on this you know I start
using and then I just you know disappear
yeah it affects all kinds of people
takes everybody in my life when I'm
saying the people that are down here on
Skid Row look like oh they're just a
bunch of homeless drug addicts but the
people like yourself who are successful
and well yeah I've rides yeah I don't
find I don't look at anybody here
down-and-out drug addicts like that I
take everybody is I mean everybody is
just like me I'm a drug addict I could
be here too
you mean I am here I'm stuck for three
weeks but you know some things I don't
sorry I don't understand I mean there's
always some kind of Avenue go I mean I'm
comin down here for three weeks looking
at this and there's always some kind of
means there's help out there there's
this and that there and alot of them
don't even don't even care about there
or do anything about that they just keep
doing you're doing this stuck in the
same thing you know kind of like I've
been stuck for three weeks but I will I
will be snap out of it like I said I
finally picked up the phone I've gone
back to work and this net and usually
this has been a good run I'm probably I
do very well in programs
yeah I mean I I program very good and
drug programs and you've gotten clean
and I get clean yeah absolutely
last I was clean for two years the last
time that this has been my longest one
this has been I was using because I was
making good money I was using this is
the most I've ever used between an
Eightball and a quarter ounce of crack a
day that's doing it non-stop and the
stuff wasn't even affecting me anymore
but when I didn't use it I would go into
panic you know me and I would get you
know very moody and this and that but
this has been my longest run so and then
ending up over here people they're just
people can't believe where I'm at right
now my twin brother over here he is what
are you doing what are you doing but I
said well I've been stuck and he's not
talking to me otherwise he would help me
but anyways it's just it's been a real
experience that just it's time to turn
it down and help myself again so yeah
you have your car I got my car back yes
and what's keeping you from just going
out to San Diego today uh today money
well it was the only thing but I hope
you I was with that okay I'll be on
you're on the freeway in ten minutes
oh if you're not in the freeway in ten
minutes head I want to give you any
money no no I'm going I'm going to my
son's first in Long Beach I told my dad
to see him before I don't go see nice
and lucky yeah
don't go see nice I couldn't believe
that nice of all of all names so you've
had all kinds of crazy stories like this
from your past oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah I
even even down and I've been even down
in San Diego when I finally found out
where because like I said my handicapped
son took us down here yeah there's a pee
really down in San Diego man I went down
there and people are just on the corner
kind of like this and they're they're
selling drugs and I ended up buying it
and I just went on a roll down there and
and I've been guns held to my head and
and just all kind of stuff and yeah my
addiction has taken me some crazy places
I've been very lucky but like I said
people
in my life really nobody's ran out on me
because they know who I am when I they
know who I am they know what I'm about
i I'm I'm help anybody I trust everybody
and that was my problem down here
I trusted everybody you know until they
burned me and I went to the expert yeah
everybody totally everybody down here is
taking and I understand I understand
that they're in survival mode and I
understand there's people down here the
mental illnesses and I mean and I take
that in consideration but just to go
ahead and have me I just don't
understand it you know people did I was
actually helping that robbed me and had
me beat up and this and that you know I
just I know it just it really made me
take another look at things that there's
some really ruthless people down here
yet I mean I mean I hate saying that
because I don't know I don't know but I
just thought I had enough and it's just
this if I just need to get out here yes
but what is it that typically triggers
you into using again
we're going out of a bender like this uh
you know it's because I am a kind of guy
I take everything on I offer well myself
I'll get a few jobs going and then I'm
making good money and I'm helping
everybody out and that's what I yeah I
know I don't think about the field I
live now and I I just everybody I help
try to help with my family as much as I
can
my brother was locked up you know I take
too much on and I just get overwhelmed
and the stuff just shuts everything out
it blocks everything out for me that's
what it does well for years I've been
asking why do I use why do I use because
it why because it I'm very hyper and it
just it shuts me down I don't think
about anything else except taking down
her head that's
that's what I do it yeah I mean and I
think I just overwhelmed myself in and I
just say [ __ ] yeah I mean so being
the Annika yam I think you know I
already know I already know once I take
that here I'm on it's on a roll
yeah I mean there's no stopping I lose I
lose all power soon as I take that hit I
lose all power but and I'm still
productive but I'm a Stan a I just you
know there's I'm not dependable but
there's certain people that that I work
for they know that and I'm very honest
my son knows everything about me he
knows everything about me I'm very open
with him
everybody does it knows everything about
me I'm not I don't lie about it
and because they know who I am and what
I'm about when I'm not using and even
when I'm using you know I do a lot yeah
I mean I do a lot to help them I but
don't don't get me wrong they're very
upset at me and they're they're tired of
me them getting hurt by my addiction you
know because I am hurting them I mean I
just disappear they're worried they
don't know what's going on and it's not
fair to them so as my mom you say just
just leave if you can do all that just
leave because you're just making
everybody miserable so that was the one
thing that mentioning my mom was my
everything she passed away of lung
cancer and it was just what three years
of fighting it she just it just it just
destroyed me it just devastated me I
couldn't believe it
there's nowhere since then huh as your
addiction been worse since then yes yes
yeah I can honestly say yes
tell me about childhood you had both
your parents um my childhood my dad was
German and he he was in my life a couple
years old so I really didn't mean he
bounced him out of my life he was really
my dad wasn't my dad he tried to be my
friend but he just but I was grew up
with a stepdad his name was Orville and
he was an alcoholic but he did
everything with us took us fishing took
us you know he did it
off-roading he just did everything with
us and he was a good man except the
alcoholism he's got real bigger with my
mom I'm young he used to beat up my mom
and this and now my mom was the type of
person that always worked and just tried
to hold the whole world on her shoulders
you know take care of everybody and she
was just a great person and we had
everything we needed and everything else
we lived well and there was really no
drastic things in our child my childhood
you know that was was devastating my
stepdad did approach me at one time
tried to have sex with me but I rolled
it off to kid he was drunk he only did
it once
ain't nothing happened nothing happened
good for you
uh-huh good for you yeah I was I was
kind of devastated by that because he
meant a lot to me because he was he was
like my dad more than my dad was and
yeah I just it kind of it did bother me
it did bother me but nothing happened I
just said no no no and what are you
doing and he anything doing so as far as
my childhood I had a pretty good
childhood you mean what school graduated
school and did all that and and then I
got a job with Freshco
at a young age and then ended up being a
plant manager there and that when I
started doing coke and but I was
functional I was very functional I was
definitely a nanny but I was very
functional until they asked me to go to
Lena Georgia and open a platform and I
went to land of George and that's when I
got hooked on the crack and it did first
date Grammy I didn't like it because I
just never satisfied smoking they just
I'm more and more so I went back to
snoring and then I did it some more and
it just grabbed me it grabbed me so I
told my boss Bob Warnock did hey
I need cuz you told me a year come up
here year hoping his plan it's been a
year I need to go back home so I go back
home no mind you look everybody I knew
everybody I knew in the 80s early 90s
snorted coke everybody did coke that's
when coke was big and when I went back
home nobody was snorting anybody he was
smoking I couldn't Wow so I started
smoking again so then I moved again and
it just hit followed me wherever I went
so anyways like I said I got clean again
and I met this girl and I got her
pregnant with triplets and I ended up in
San Diego because that's where my son
was in the hospital for a year and I got
in the construction I took a leave from
the produce company and I got any
construction and I took off I mean I
made a lot of different people and I did
well I stayed clean for a long time and
then like I said I ran into Imperial
Street downtown San Diego and it was
haunting me that I knew where to get it
now and I went down there one day and
got it and went on another run so but
this one has been my longest and then
the uses has been great just I can't
believe you know all the money I've been
making has just been going to this and
and and not helping people I need help
and they're like we're all your money
going we're all your money going even
the guy I'm doing the massage parlor for
you know he's been hands and thousands
and I got four grand left on that it's
it's all gone yeah I mean because of
this that and and I'm gonna tell you and
most these tricks I didn't have sex with
I just got took yeah I mean and and this
is the first time I really been doing
and been doing a the prostitute thing
yeah I mean I've really never got into
that or anything else but down here I
was trying to get the dope and this and
that they drew me in you know me wanting
to have sex and didn't get high so
yeah it's just this hasn't been a good
experience has been not been a good
experience and maybe that's good for me
you mean maybe that's gonna turn me
around because I'm definitely getting
that hell out of here so I'll play this
video and being able to see it and know
that it's exposed out in there in the
real world might just help you take
ownership fingers possibility for yeah
the situation you get yourself into oh
yeah I just yeah well I didn't think
about that open a few people don't see
it but that's okay sorry about that
that's okay that's no that's okay it's
okay it's okay
what I found is sometimes admitting it
I'm losing it exhaling you own it helps
you get past it exactly to hide off the
height it keeps it alive exactly exactly
exactly yeah so that that's that's
that's not a problem it's not a problem
it's good sometimes I'm feeling a little
bit nervous but it's it's alright it's a
good thing it is I'm not worried about
it sometimes confession is powerful yeah
yeah yeah so they'll be glad to hear
that I've been taking advantage of input
to the ringer I'm gonna send you south
from here if you're not in the freeway
in five minutes okay okay alright but
yeah thank you so much for talking okay
okay
you